but i'm in the back doing it over there
and then around
tilt his body and then around
boom tilt and around
hill and around okay
okay so only on the left side come in
get the collar not only good but i'm
pushing him
into my forearm you can't let him off
the bottom
can't let him out the bottom if you lose
it
now pull this side
right here in my form you see this uh
his collar is on one side
and my wrist bones on the other
but you really don't have to okay
but don't let him fall through the
bottom
he's going don't think you're gonna get
it now
do the whole thing he gets his grip
you're not going to get it you can't
take that much control over me okay
so it's his progress he goes warm
he never gets it very important
oh he never gets it
but i'm not ahead again
[Music]
the dogs start cutting down prematurely
it has to go over his head um
use this hand
over his head
don't expect you can be some crazy
gymnastics please no
no
boom
then find your projection points
wherever his body is that's what you
throw
so
you